well after years of performing alongside
a dj mike xavier decided to create his
own live experience that's unparalleled
in the world of hip-hop and he joins us
today to talk all things hip-hop and
poetry and he has a special event coming
up this weekend and he's also here
alongside tell me your name the one and
only zeke i knew you'd get a better
intro than me
you guys thank you so much for being
here this is such a cool experience
you're performing at brooklyn bowl tell
me a little bit about the show and what
people can expect so it's a curated
lineup of hip-hop and spoken word
artists it's really something that's
unique because a lot of times you get
either or but in this case you're going
to have talented performers on both
sides of it whether they're doing spoken
word or they have some tracks even like
a drummer behind them it's just going to
be a really unique experience and just a
lot of fun overall i love that spoken
word has become more and more popular i
mean now we're seeing it on america's
got talent and all of these reality
shows that we never really saw before
how important is it for you to continue
to kind of grow that side of the arts
and introduce new people to it it's very
important because it's something that
really speaks to people's soul and you
know sometimes people don't even speak
on what they're going through but they
might hear a poem that really touches
them and affects them in a way that they
don't even express to other people and
so a lot of times after the show i'll
get people that will you know reach out
to me and say like this really helped me
out like it was therapeutic and i needed
this so thank you for putting this
together so to be on a platform like
this to get the word out is so
appreciated because i know that people
would enjoy it if they come out to the
show absolutely and you know with the
show you're bringing in friends and
people to perform alongside you so i'm
going to bring you into the conversation
here what can we expect from from your
performance at brooklyn bowl um yes so
i'm a rapper okay
and rap in its essence are the acronym
for rhythm and poetry so i also do
spoken words i'm part of the spotlight
slam team so i do a little bit of spoken
word a little bit of rap so
i appreciate mike for hosting these
events because it allows me to blend
both of those worlds
with an audience who's anticipating you
know both experiences well and you have
a performance to give us a taste and
i'll get to that in just a second but
before i want to let everyone know if
they want to come see the show where and
when and how can they get tickets so
it's this friday may 20th uh doors are
at 7 show starts at eight and they can
purchase tickets at hip hop and poetry
dot com and we're also on instagram
under hip hop and poetry so easy to find
you guys thank you so much for being
here the show's gonna be awesome zeke
i'll let you take it away if you don't
mind
see it
time is of the essence every day is a
blessing i had a second to myself and
decided reflecting would be the best use
of time for my peace of mind instead of
scrolling through the socials like i do
from six to nine entertainment as of
late has been my biggest vice it keeps
my mind off what's important so i sleep
at night but the problem with running is
my problems come back and when i don't
deal with them i know my problems start
to stack now i'm feeling overwhelmed and
the burnout kicking in so i'm staying to
myself in fear i don't fit in voices in
my head say i'm the only person
struggling not to be a burden i just
stay up in that bubbling pray that it'll
end but faith dies without work i can't
heal on my own hit my people when i'm
hurt i can make it out this hole just
keep working on my work but when it's
time to jump it's important to stay
alert so i don't miss my chance to stay
stuck in this loop gotta keep filling my
cup like matthew throw in the coop gotta
take my leap of faith like the kid off
the stoop and keep on spitting my truth
make it do what it do
wow
awesome
be sure to go check out hip hop and
poetry night this friday may 20th at
brooklyn bowl las vegas doors open at 7.
thank you guys so much i feel inspired
now i'm coming you guys inspired me to
come it's a great